il n'y a rien dans le début de sa vidéo
clip qui laisse deviner ce que dans
l'ombre
glover s'apprête à dire aux américains
une danse envoûté le rythme festif même
compte agir
puis ils nous offrent le pire des états
unis il société ou ensemble prendre
mieux soin des armes à feu que des
hymnes on le sent à peine y signer il ne
recommence à danser cette fois avec des
enfants qu'on ne se lasse pas de voir
bouger pour que ça va on est dans une
dynamique wascat des tueries de masse on
est riche et passionné il once again
dents longues over a lancé la chanson
samedi alors qu'il animait star edena
glaive un véritable tour de force pour
l'acteur réalisateur a peur que du pour
ses rôles au grand écran mais surtout
pour la télésérie atlanta qui l'a écrite
dans laquelle il incarne le gérant d'un
chanteur qui est propre une série primée
au cours d'une gourde qui abordent
l'avenir de la génération y et la
question raciale
avec brio mais avec des ciseaux mercat
son alter ego du rar carnegie gabino
s'établit comme artiste engagé il ne
laisse personne indifférent
[Musique]
fait revivre le massacre de l'église de
charlton la brutalité policière le chaos
quatre minutes bourru de symboles et
ironique terrifiant
depuis sa sortie la vidéo a été vue plus
de 65 millions de fois
l'internet est aussi envahi de réaction
et de discussions sur l'interprétation à
donner à ces cinq qui bascule entre
l'horreur et le fond des jo
est ce que ces deux-là la provocation
marketing le débat dans ce jeu de
l'engagement et je vois aussi une
utilisation
c'était créative de la violence la
violence dans les ghettos américains qui
sont peuplées comment parler à la
population noire aux etats unis pas
souvent sous silence
on se questionne un peter en bout de
ligne c'est le seul et le réalisateur à
connaître vraiment le fond de l'air
chose leur vision qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient faire avec ça et c'est ce qui
fait la puissance de cette vidéo où il
disparaît en courant traqués et
pourchassés
il nous laisse sans réponse mais il
branler is it amaral tedesco radio
canada montréal
[Musique]